en Ukraine au moins une centaine de
d'attaquants ont été menées par des
forces russes selon les autorités de
Kiev ces attaques ont été repoussés le
long de la ligne de front des soldats
russes contre un de rebrousser chemin en
direction de Liman barmouth ou encore
marine correspondance d'Emmanuel chas
depuis qui a
cette dernière 24 heures en tout ce sont
six personnes qui ont qui ont péri sous
les bombardements russes 27 autres ont
été blessés dans l'est du pays en tout
il y a plus il y a eu plus d'une
centaine
d'assaut russe contre des
infrastructures
civiles donc les civils qui vraiment
sont les premières victimes de ce
conflit je vous rappelle ce chiffre des
Nations Unies 22000 victimes notamment
au cours de ces bombardements en tout
depuis février dernier ce sont plus de
8100 personnes décédées des civils
décédés plus de 13000 blessés et puis on
voit dans ces frappes dans ces
bombardements qui qui touchent surtout
l'est du pays mais pas seulement des
bombardements qui qui ont lieu en
général aussi sur tout le pays à
intervalles assez régulier je rappelle
que les troupes russes utilisent
finalement tout ce qu'il possède des
missiles des drones parfois même il y a
des accusations d'utilisation de bombes
à sous munition de tirs de mortier donc
les civils première victime de cette
guerre